- You know?
- What?
- You know.
- What? No, I don't know.
You tell me.
- Hi, I'm Brooke, and we've
been dating for three years.
- Hi, my name is Rita.
And we've been dating for three years.
- I want to see if that's the same answer.
Because it was off and on
so much in the beginning.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm nervous about
playing this game because--
- You're not sure what I'm gonna say.
I'm excited because I want
to see what she has to say
and I haven't heard these questions
or anything before, so...
I wanna know.
(laughing)
- When did I first masturbate?
(laughing) Oh my god.
Actually, I remember,
I watched, for the first time, Top Gun.
Like, yeah, I was so turned on
about the movie (laughing).
- So, wait, who did you masturbate to?
- You have to watch the movie,
you haven't watched the movie.
- No, I haven't watched the movie.
- It's when Tom Cruise
is about to have sex
with Kelly McGillis I think is her name.
I watched the movie, like, repeatedly.
So, probably, I was like 11.
- Okay.
When was my first kiss?
I think it was, like,
when I was really little.
I was like a toddler.
I was in a pool and I almost drowned
because I got all this water in my mouth.
(laughing)
- Okay, free space.
Ask me what you want.
- I can ask you anything.
Hmm. Hmm hmm.
Who was your best sexual
partner, including me?
- Of course you. (laughing)
- How did I lose my virginity?
That's fun.
I remember specifically
the song that was playing,
because, like, I only wanted
to have sex to this song.
At the time I was dating
my first, like, relationship ever.
We had to get really drunk,
because I didn't want to, like,
I didn't know what to do.
So I wanted to be really drunk.
And we played that song
and like, we had it on repeat.
And then we went up to the bedroom
and then--
- Ah, you kind of planned
that you were gonna have sex that day.
- I guess.
It wasn't a good experience.
I think it was, like, it hurt.
And I was drunk.
And I had a massive hangover the next day.
- (laughing) Interesting.
Okay.
How many partners have I had?
- Who?
- You already know who.
Brenda was my first one,
for 15 years,
Allison for a couple of years,
and you for three years.
- I'm glad I didn't get that question.
- Why are you glad that you
didn't get that question?
- Because (laughing) on
our on and off stages
in the beginning, you know...
- What?
- We weren't together, so.
So what?
- You know?
- What, no, I don't know. You tell me.
(laughing)
That's not an answer.
- Um, yeah.
- How many?
- What?
- How many partners have you had?
(laughing)
- Uh, three.
- Three?
Who?
- Okay, there was one
two and three.
- Who?
- No!
No, next, I'm going now.
(laughing)
Am I in love with you?
Yes.
- Are you sure?
- No, I'm not anymore.
(laughing)
- I really liked that.
- Bet you did.
- I loved it.
(laughing)
- Yeah, three partners.
Hmm, we'll talk about it after.
- I think that was more
exciting than I thought
because I learned something new.
- I feel like it was the right time
because you always learn something new
from your partners,
so I'm glad that I did it right now
and not before.
- I think other couples
should play this game
because it is a learning experience
and I'll never forget this.
- It was really good.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Top Gun? You still
talking about Top Gun?
(laughing)